la tâche était colossal parcourir tout
le sud du québec
au delà de cinq cent cinquante mille
kilomètres carrés pour tracer le nouveau
portrait des oiseaux qui nichent un
projet de science citoyenne et
participative comme on en voit peu au
québec
encadrés par des scientifiques plus de
1800 en ethnologue ont participé
bénévolement à la cueillette de données
sur la répartition et l'abondance de nos
oiseaux
le biologiste michel robert était le
coordonnateur du projet il faut être
grandement passionné il faut croire pas
seulement dans le projet comme nat lens
il faut il faut aimer les oiseaux et
penser qu'on a besoin de les étudier
pour être même de bien les protéger
l'ouvragé par un 25 ans après la
réalisation du premier atlas des oiseaux
nicheurs du québec
les constats qu'on y fait confirme
certains changements observés depuis des
années une diminution des oiseaux
champêtre entre autres liés à la
transformation de leur habitat et des
grandes cultures mais aussi des gains
chez certains rapaces qui ont entre
autres tirer profit du retrait depuis
des décennies du ddt un puissant
insecticide
au delà de la publication leur travail a
surtout permis de constituer une base de
données phénoménal qui sera très utile à
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
et aux organismes de protection et de
conservation de la faune ici andré
bernard radio canada montréal